is there a formula
of your monthly income you make five
thousand after taxes
thirty percent of your there is a
ballpark around thirty percent just to
keep it simple okay
around thirty percent but that will
qualify you however you also have to
qualify for
about about 40 including all of your
debts
so one thing that people don't realize
is that don't forget about the debt
the debt is really important it means 30
is the following if you're making and by
the way are you saying net income or
you're saying
gross income so tax taxes have to come
out too of that but
it's forty percent of your gross income
handles your mortgage check this i'm
giving you round numbers
i get that but if you're saying if i'm
if i'm netting eight grand a month
okay if i'm netting eight grand a month
thirty percent of that so now you've got
but then the bigger number which really
affects most people
is 40 of that or 3 200 has to do the
mortgage the taxes the insurance if
there's mortgage insurance
but less than 20 down maintenance if
you're buying a condo
and in addition to that all of your
debts your car payments
your minimum you know what this means so
this means alimony child support that
foreign loans that 500 000 house we just
looked at the only person that should
buy it is somebody that's
netting 8 000 a month somebody who's
who's
pretty much pretty much maybe maybe more
but but it doesn't have to be bothered
there's going to be two incomes too no
of course but what's net net is 12 a
month so you're making 11 or something
like that yeah you're making 150 so that
means a 500 000
house is live by somebody that's making
a household income of 150 per year
pre-taxes but but patrick this is where
your personal situation think about it
that's
why the median house is 800 but if
somebody's getting anything if somebody
likes to eat home every night and
they're not going to do that
they may have more discretionary income
maybe they're going to go to 3 000 right
somebody who likes you know
clothes shopping and vacations more that
you have to that's why i said
your means and your lifestyle as the
last how much would you add i know you
gave the five points here which was very
helpful the audience is uh uh uh
taking a lot of notes with this and they
sent a message this year number five
for me what would you put value for uh
your the house was built you know
meaning is it a
2005 build it's so 2005 at 222 square
feet
uh dollars per square foot versus 2017
260 how much value do you put on what
year the house was the home was built
so you can almost estimate that homes
are going to be around for like 60 or 70
years right and the average home in the
united states today is close to 40 years
old i mean think about that it's 41 to
be exactly
an average house average average age is
40 years old 41. so
so a 10 year difference probably doesn't
mean too much patrick in your example
so long as it's in good condition that's
why if you're going to buy a home
without an expense and an inspection you
could be putting yourself at some risk
okay i i i think that there's exactly a
challenge there's nothing to them
yeah so 10 years so if i have a house
one is built in 2016 one is built in
2006.
you're looking at the house the 2006 is
250 square foot
the 2016 is 280 square foot how do you
judge that it's close enough
it's close you don't care so you would
go 16 16. it's
it's just we said do i like the home
that's number one got it but then after
that how does it compare to
other homes like that on square footage
i got another question that just came up
here folks if you got questions here
post it on twitter because we're
actually going through kai if you want
to go on twitter and pull up all the
pbd podcast pbd podcast you can put my
handle in there it's easier to find at
patrickbet david the question is
so this is from chile childress what a
great name chili childress
so i'm on the verge of putting my house
two-bedroom
one-bath ranch that was down to studs
remodel one year ago on the market i
bought it last july here on southeastern
mass
for 275 and it's now an estimated 321.
so he went from 275 800
to 321. should i sell now or
hold a little longer okay so a couple of
things so first of all
because i happen to see it people are
asking about debt income ratios yeah i
said 40
remember i said round number could you
exceed that certainly could go up a
little bit there's gonna be compensating
i'm just giving you round numbers so
people could do quick by the way i
like the fact that you're giving
conservative numbers because a lot of
people are saying go higher i would much
rather go where you're going then go the
higher enough yes
now with this particular case here's
what you have to think of so it appears
that you made a profit and
if you're married the first five hundred
thousand dollars of profit is free
if you're single the first 250 thousand
dollars of profit is free from tax
what is that a homestead right there no
that's just the federal income tax so
there's no there's no first home by
homeowner or
anybody anybody anybody so what what we
have to think of here is okay
how much money did you put into it how
much money did you pay for closing costs
getting in
how much are you going to spend if you
list it with a real estate agent or
whatever to get
out and then where are you going to go
so before you ask
should i sell i think you should ask
yourself should i be buying what do i
want to buy i think you need to go right
back to that list
does this home no longer fit my needs
and if it doesn't then i have to buy
something can i find something first
and then you can put your house and make
that decision folks barry habib if
you're enjoying today's podcast smash
the thumbs up button
as well as subscribe to the channel if
you want to hear more barry he'll be
maybe even bringing him back to talk
more and to
talk about real estate press that thumbs
up button again if you got questions
hashtag pbdpodcast on twitter great
stuff we're learning so far five things
when you're looking into buying a house
number one does it fit your family goals
number two is time horizon
number three is the potential upside
potential of the house number four is
uh look at the cost per square feet and
number five is your budget
typically 30 to 40 percent of your gross
monthly income
you can get a little bit more aggressive
than that but 30 is the number typically
to look at so patrick if we can i want
to talk a little bit about something
that has to do with
creating some wealth for you with real
estate sure and i know we focused a
little bit about buying a home but
the home ownership rate in the united
states is 66 so perhaps 66 percent of
people are listening is that
average is that higher is that lower
what's the number
the highest that it ever was was in 2005
when it was at nine point four percent
so let's say roughly seven
seventy percent home ownership rate was
the highest that's when they were
handing out houses like for nothing
yes exactly so it's 66 percent it's
healthy
certain markets like in california it's
typically 55 that's how they've dealt
with the
the costs going up is it shaped a little
bit of the homeownership rate however
that 55
still overwhelms the available supply 40
is 55 but that but
but that 55 is more than the supply and
that's why prices keep going up
so what i want to talk about is the
people that are listening that own a
home
you really need to look at your mortgage
situation right now because there's
things that you could do
that could set your kids up for college
that could set you up for retirement and
that can create enormous wealth and give
you the life
that you really deserve and use your
mortgage
people look at a mortgage and it's crazy
they look at it like they're buying a
flat screen tv and all they care about
is the rate
that's not what the important thing is
the important thing is the strategy
so for example what we see a lot of and
we advise a lot of mortgage
professionals to do this and we get
hundreds and thousands of stories of
people that have changed individuals
life so
let's just say if you have a mortgage
right now and you're saying i shouldn't
refinance because
my rate is i don't let's say you got in
it two and a half percent
and you see rates today a little over
three and let's even go crazy say they
go up a little bit to three and a
quarter three and a half
people are not thinking about
refinancing but what you're forgetting
is like any good
coach in football would say you know
take what the defense gives you so what
we've been given here is this
appreciation
so two things have happened to your home
it's appreciated and you've been making
your mortgage payments so you've
amortized the loan
you've gained equity in just the past
year anybody who's paying mortgage
insurance
you probably can refinance and save that
but the magic really happens
with your debt because if you were to
say what we see oftentimes is let's just
take a typical family
20 000 in credit card debt one car loan
they've got a chevy
it's 29 000 car loan they've got
a little bit of best buy they've got a
little bit of nordstroms or whatever it
is
a few things nothing crazy you take that
family
you say okay let's take your debt pay it
all off
included in the mortgage even if the
rate's one percent higher
right so going from two and a half to
three and a half let's just say
you could save about eighteen hundred
dollars a month in cash flow but here's
the real key
don't take that eighteen hundred dollars
of found money and go blow it
take that eighteen hundred dollars and
pour it back into the mortgage
so if you bought your home three years
ago now you got 27 years left normally
yep
you change it to 11 years left on your
mortgage
no payments in five years you gain a
hundred and ten thousand dollars
in ten years you gain two hundred and
seventy thousand dollars in 11 years
when the things paid off
320 000 benefit that'll pay for your
kids college and you saved
15 years of making your mortgage payment
at 4 000 bucks a month
it's the best retirement plan you could
have there you go barry you'll be
okay on how to do kai's back they're
taking notes did you get that guy
did you learn yes okay good now let me
let me read you something that's going
on here this is a realtor.com story
the housing markets show signs of
softening has it topped out right
over the past few weeks the rate of
price growth has begun to slow fewer
buyers are seeking mortgages to purchase
homes
the competition for available homes
while still formidable may not be quite
as
intense as it's been and this could
provide buyers a sorely needed opening
the markets topping out says mark
zandy chief economist at moody's
analytics
it's starting to show cracks it feels
like we've hit the apex and we're moving
to the other side of it
that does not mean there's a bubble on
the verge of popping and the prices are
about to plummet in a free
free fall reminiscent of the last
housing bus that we had according to
economists and housing experts
some of april's rise was due to the
comparison to a year earlier april 2020
was the beginning of cover 19 and was
local restrictions general fear over the
virus hampered real estate markets but
that's not what the whole story is
january of this year
when prices were up 15.4 percent
compared to january of 2020
which was well before the pandemic so
then the next story i'll put both of
them together and you tell me your
thoughts on this
is another housing bubble building this
is a street story
same exact thing they quoted mark zandy
as well
but it says the price has dominated
financial news recently for renters
the price of an average apartment takes
up an even greater
ever greater share of personal income
every year this is particularly true in
big
cities where a one bedroom apartment can
often cost
between twenty five hundred dollars to
three thousand dollars a month but the
real headlines have been in the market
for single family housing in many
communities home prices
have increased by 30 to 50 percent in
just the past two years
this has led the median prices home over
twenty thousand dollars nationwide to
nearly five hundred thousand dollars in
the towns and suburbs
near major cities which is kind of what
you were talking about so there's so
much misconception there's a lot of
better
tell us what it is okay so there's a lot
so first of all i know mark mark's a
friend
okay interestingly enough at john burns
conference three years ago we debated
this
i said the housing market was going up
three years ago he was not big
in favor of the housing market going up
the way i was but uh
right there but so so i understand where
mark's coming from but what you're
seeing there what you're seeing there is
what you're seeing
is number one again the use of median
home price
this is a misconception median home
price is not appreciation now somebody
said 15.4
appreciation i have no idea where they
pulled that out of because that's just
wrong
there's no way it's 15.4 the latest data
that we have and i said i said we're
going to get new data today from
from case-shiller which is the gold
standard this is the way you're really
supposed to measure it but the most
recent was 13
again which is what you said earlier
that's really really hot levels of
appreciation
but the in order for there to first of
all when they talk
here's the main concept we have to
understand
when you look at the housing market
there's the housing market
that's the driver of gdp that generates
economic activity
and then there's the housing market i'm
buying a home for myself and i want to
know am i going to make money am i going
to lose money i'm going to create wealth
two different ways to look at it and
what the consumer gets confused on is
the media looks at
the housing market as the driver of gdp
and sales are slowing
sales are not slowing because the
market's bad
sales are slowing because there's
nothing for sale there's nothing to buy
so
if i have when when you know the new
airpods came out
the airpod pros and you wanted them but
you go to apple and they didn't have
them in stock it doesn't mean sales are
slowing
there's so much demand that they don't
have enough of it so
sales are slow because you don't have
enough supplies same thing in the
housing market the other thing people
get confused upon
any person who looks at stocks we know
that it's a stock market but really it's
a market
of stocks you can go to healthcare you
can go to technology you can go to
whatever you have many different sectors
biotech right so
a dozen major sectors exactly in the
housing market
you have to divide it into sectors
there's your first time home buyers
sector
there's your you know move up buyer
sector there's your more affluent areas
there's the premium price homes
so look at all of those as sectors
interesting point of view
so if you if you do it then the picture
gets clearer because then you could say
okay well
sales are slowing but where are they
slowing they're certainly not slowing on
the upper end they're picking up they're
doubling
they're slowing on the lower now the
majority of homes do take place on the
lower end okay
we know that but there's just not a lot
of inventory because remember
in any market if you're gonna say
there's a bubble what's the definition
of it the definition of a bubble
is that there is too much supply not
enough demand
and therefore prices will come down we
have the exact opposite and the demand
is going to get stronger
barry i remember when guys were speaking
the way you were speaking okay everybody
was saying oh my god there's two
communities back in 2006. it was the
angelo
what was his name oh my gosh and he
looked like you he looked like uh
he's one of these mafia bosses right
very good looking guy
very tan like you a good looking guy
like you and he would get up and say hey
you know it's going to continue it's
going to do this it's going to do that
countrywide ryan people oh my gosh
he's right and you know there was a
new century what was it uh there was a
bunch of these companies out there
that were doing a lot of loans new
century i believe new central central i
was
remember the correspondence they were
paying on the back and which was
ridiculous guys making 400 grand a month
like oh my gosh
this is going to continue like this and
they were convincing they were so
convincing
then there was the michael burries of
the world like listen guys this shit's
not going to last like this for a long
time
so i think the biggest thing you know
the camp i was in i was in 2006 i was
getting hate mail per say the market was
frothy well here's my question for you
here's my question for you
who the hell should the audience believe
in everybody's here we go okay
here we go go for it number one when you
take a look at the comparison to 2007
yep let's do it okay
so first of all there were 3.7 million
homes for sale in 2007.
today there's 1.05 million homes for
sale so the supplies that's a big
numbers 3.7 million homes for sale in
2007 today 1.05 million and the latest
data will show that that number
has been cut in the third three million
less homes but wait hold on here's
more importance in 2007 yeah everyone in
the united states lived
under 116 million roots there was 116
million households
the latest data is from 2020 there were
128 million households 12 more
12 million more households 3 million
fewer homes and you wonder why prices
are going up how can that market go down
now somebody might say
okay forbearance foreclosure we should
talk about that because another big
misconception the media gets it
completely wrong on this so first of all
most of them don't know how to spell
forbearance forget about understanding
it and by the way it's kind of hard to
spell
so when you take a look at forbearance
what does that mean think of it
as a pause button on your player
you pause the payments now when they
came out with the cares act
what they did was they rushed to bring
this out there and they made the
forbearance
so that you didn't have to prove
hardship so a lot of people said wait a
minute
i don't have to make my payment there's
no penalty there's no interest for 12
months
how does forbearance work when it's all
over at the end of the
forbearance period you don't have to
make a payment here's all my back
payments
it kind of rides along your first
mortgage as a second mortgage with no
interest no payments
and you're able to pay that off and
satisfy it when you either refinance
pay off your home or sell your home so
that's when you put so those are going
to be
very staggered it's not going to cause
any turbulence in the market
and if those properties came on if there
were a problem with them it's like
dropping a water can on the desert you
know we need the inventory
but now think about the resumption of
payments so
a big portion of people who took
forbearance they didn't need it
so many people who took forbearance got
their home got their jobs back
if they did need it so they should have
no problem because they qualify sure
there will be a segment of the
population that they're the through
forbearance
heaven forbid we feel awful for these
poor folks but they now can't make their
payment
what the vast vast vast vast majority
will be able to do
put their home on the market probably
sell it in a week pocket a ton of cash
from it
so they're not going to let those homes
go into the marketplace
under foreclosure or under duress this
is not 2
000 listen to this in 2009 26
of homes owned more on their mortgage
than the value of the home
today there is less than two percent
where the value of the mortgage is
higher than the value of the home this
is what they call underwater yeah
underwater 27 in 2009 exactly now it's
only two percent
less than two percent so it's not even
comparable to two thousand and here's
the other thing too
let's talk let's talk about loans 90
days delinquent loans 90 days liquid
people look at that
and i saw there was an article that you
have so they say okay loans 90 days
delinquent
two percent of loans in 90 days look in
a normal market
it's 1.5 so we're people forget they
just show the headline and they don't
show
what the variance is we just went
through a pandemic so yes that has gone
up a little bit
loan's actually in foreclosure it is a
quarter
of one percent so that's one out of four
hundred homes you add to that
the homes that are on free and clear
which is 34 now you're talking if you
took a helicopter you looked over 500
600 homes
only one of those homes is in
foreclosure that's one too many but yeah
the number says an estimated 10 million
americans are behind in the mortgage
payments and 1.7 million or
90 days past due that's two percent four
times as many as the uh before the
pandemic
that's incorrect information that is not
four times as many that's from
sentinel and the sun sentinel is wrong
because if you do the math on it as you
probably did in your head that's two
percent
right roughly 10 million on what not 10
million go to the 90 days plus
1.7 million okay so that's there's 80 86
million homes so
roughly two percent okay right so then
you got two percent of homes
used to be one and a half percent the
variance is it's that's not four times
about they may be talking about the 10
million our past due
but if they're counting people that went
into forbearance yeah okay
but they had a free pass they had a
whole pass not to make their payments
biggest difference is when you're saying
3.7 million to 1 million
that's just ridiculous i mean so if you
look at the markers to see what happened
in 06 versus today
i remember all the homes that builders
were building like crazy
riverside county had a 64 foreclosure
rate at one point
you'd go the literally you're walking
the streets six out of ten homes it's
trash no one's living there
somebody just walked away from it
because patrick was in california this
is an 0708 it was
riverside was detroit people were gaming
the housing market to try and make
profit because it was going up and
people were flipping homes
so one person was buying five homes they
didn't qualify for any of the five they
could fog up five mirrors
but they got mortgages on five homes
today that one person's buying a home
for the home they need to live in
that's like the movie the big short
michael bury was like talking to the
girl and steve carell
there was a stripper that had five uh
that was the part yeah
yeah yeah matter of fact that stripper
was in rock of ages just so you know
that good girl by the way
yeah so go back good investor yeah
question kai pull up twitter
pull up twitter pull up twitter katarina
kavar
okay katarina cavar asks a question
saying
longer loan and smaller payments or
shorter loans higher payments catalina
you've got to go
with what fits your lifestyle the best
and if you have a
if you have a way to take the difference
so let's just say
longer term and smaller payments right
so let's just use some numbers let's say
it's a
it's a thousand dollar payment versus a
fifteen hundred dollar payment
my question to you catherine is what are
you gonna do if you could afford the
payment so now you have both options so
what are you gonna do with the 500 bucks
and where are you going to invest it
because if you do invest it into your
mortgage into a shorter term
that's going to give you a quicker
payoff it's going to put you in a
position where you're going to be
building equity over time you don't have
to wait until the loan's paid off
you're building much more equity it's
got an amazing effect people don't
realize it
so what happens is is that when you make
additional payments on your mortgage
you get the benefit because then every
single subsequent payment
is based on the lower remaining
principal balance so a greater portion
of
every single payment after that more
goes towards principal
so it builds on itself look if you have
another
80 of america that's good it's really
good
yeah it is really of course but if you
have a business opportunity if you could
put that 500
a month in something that's going to
generate you know eight nine ten
less than five percent it's not good
because where are you going to put it
safely in the bank you know the the so
the definition of the risk-free rate is
about one percent it's very good answer
because you're giving the the audience
perspective to know
that it may make sense for some and it
may not make sense for others
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you